You said
that you wanted
this end to the saga to be ambitious
with your character. Yes.
What does that mean?
And do you think
this movie pulls that off?
I meant that
I wanted it to be character driven,
and I wanted us
to confront the question of age
straight on, not to,
you know, not to try to hide my age,
but to take advantage of it
in the telling of the story
And do you think the movie
pulls that off, that
what you would hope for?
I feel very strongly that it does.
One thing that I loved about the movie,
among many
things, is the fact that there were
inside jokes.
For those of us who have followed
you and followed
in the
sense writers of the lost ark in 1981
and this are going to show
a scene from 81.
You then and you now take a look
back
the lesson
seems to be never bring a sword or a whip
to a gunfight. Gunfight.
Yeah I think you're right
That guy the swordsman right
in the original your original writers
had work for months
to perfect his skills with the Scimitar.
Right.
And we were to have filmed a four day
whip and Scimitar
fight in a in a marketplace.
And I was suffering from
dysentery.
And so were many members of the crew,
not Steven,
because he
every time we went in the shower,
he put gaffer tape over his mouth.
Stephen
King traveled with
with a trunk full of SpaghettiOs,
but he didn't have decent work.
So it was up to me to say
listen, I can't stay out of the
dressing room for very long.
Should we
think about cutting this down?
Let's just shoot this son of a bitch.
And Steven said,
I was just thinking about that myself.
And it worked like gangbusters.
Yeah,
but it was a terrible disappointment
to the poor guy
that had been
working all this time to perfect.
Well,
I hope you paid him for the five days.
I'm sure they did. Yeah.
You have said that playing indie
was is a joy and has been a joy for you.
Why?
And is it a little bit
bittersweet
to have to say goodbye to him?
No, no.
It's a time for me to grow up.
Six years ago, I
I thought maybe we ought to take a shot
at making another one.
And I wanted it to be about age
because I think that rounds out the story
that we've told.
And speaking to this issue of age,
not making jokes about it, but
but making it a real thing,
I am also a big fan of 1923
the prequel to Yellowstone
where you play Jacob Dutton
who is trying to hold on to his ranch
against the ravages
and threats from progress. Take a look
They're in a mine
right above this
four inches main water supply.
They on the property to the north
and to the south
to squeeze what's in the middle
and what's in the middle.
Associate
Justice of the luxury
My concern is survival.
Do you ever feel that way
in real life as your work goes for movies
to streaming
and we face a world
of artificial intelligence?
Are you the kind of person
who embraces change or kind of holds it
at a distance?
I mean, when it's helpful,
I'm happy to have it and when it's
when it's not.
I'm I'm disappointed
that we've chosen to use it.
Are there instances that you think.
I think it's not a question
of the technology. It's how you use it.
I mean,
we have the capacity
to generate
more enemies
than anyone would ever face before,
more airplanes in the sky than any
one would ever see.
But what
happens is you lose human scale.
And if you lose that,
you lose the ability, the
the audience's ability
to to to experience
it consistent with the characters,
the story that you're telling.
And and that's that it's almost
it's it's too easy.
Speaking of technology,
I don't want to give away
too much of the Indy five,
but the movie begins
in the well towards the end of World
War Two.
You're back
fighting the Nazis
as you were in Raiders of the Lost Ark.
And through some technological winter
wizardry.
80 year old
Harrison Ford looks exactly like 40 year
old Harrison Ford.
Do you understand how they did that?
Not completely,
but it is 40 year
old Harrison Ford,
and that's why it looks so good.
Lucasfilm,
I've been working for Lucasfilm
most of my adult life.
Every frame of film that those
that are used in the
in the in the films
that we made together
and those that are not all all
every frame of film
could be mined with here.
Here we go again.
Artificial intelligence
And they could find the right angle,
the right light.
So that's my mouth.
My eyes, my face.
Married.
And it is
and it's
it's not Photoshopped or anything.
It doesn't look that way. No, it's real.
I've literally I'm thinking to myself
as I'm watching it
Did he shoot parts of Indiana
Jones five back
when he was doing Raiders
of the Lost Ark?
Because it really was seamless.
It was beautiful.
Yeah.
You've made more than 70 films
which have grossed more than $9 billion.
And obviously the movies were great.
But do you have any
do you have any thoughts
about why
it is that for so many years,
so many people have wanted to sit
in the dark and watch you
They're not watching me.
They're watching a movie
in which I play various characters.
I think that
because I was 35 40 years old
at really the height of
of Hollywood's influence over the culture
and vice versa,
we we were enjoying
a very
good time to be in the movie business.
Well, I have another theory about this
that I want to test with you
I think your secret sauce, Harrison Ford,
is your vulnerability.
And I want to explore this
a little bit with you.
Here's a scene of you as Jack Ryan
in the middle of an ambush
by the drug cartel
and clear and present danger.
I think
you look as scared and shaken
as we think we are
if, God forbid,
we should ever be in that situation.
I have always I've been accused
of playing heroes.
I don't play heroes.
I play a CIA man or a or a doctor
or whatever it is.
But you cannot play a hero.
You have to play
your audience.
You have to
bring your audience into that moment.
And what?
What, what?
And you want them
to feel emotionally consistent
with the characters,
because then
then we're not talking about the story.
The audience is immersed in the story.
It's it.
It's a whole different thing.